hà nổi thì kia độ chung vềng tháng được giữ báo phục biến trong 18 mươi trên 18 mươi
lượng mưa khoảng 30,000 mươi trên 25 mươi trên 20 mươi, bây giờ bây giờ mấy mươi mết,
sau đó tăng lên 15 mươi trên 15 mươi trong 30 giữ mà cuối tháng.
Lòng cai thì có kia độ chung vềng từ 18 mươi, 15 mươi, 15 mươi,
thuộc ngóm cao nhất của vực gình nũ phía bác, của bơi tổng lượng mưa khoảng 30,000 mươi,
tổng lã khu vực nống nhất cả nước, hãy về độ chung vềng tháng được giữ báo phục ba mốt,
cho đi báo mi hai độ. Còn nhất trong các trạm khi tựng đại diễn trên cân lực, trong khi đó,
tại một dưới chi đến cho chung vềng từ 20,000 mươi, 20 mươi, 15 mươi, 15 mươi,
tăng dần về độ quay tháng khi giống mùa thế làm hợp mạnh hợp.
Tại năng bộ thì nếu đổ chung vềng tháng hợp thành vô hồ gì,
bây giờ đọc 12,5 mươi, 15 mươi, 15 mươi, 15 mươi, 15 mươi, 15 mươi,
cân thơ có trị độ phố biến từ 20,5 mươi, 15 mươi, 15 mươi, 15 mươi, 15 mươi,
mươi giống báo là giá tăng từ giữa tháng, sông trước thời điểm mưa sức hiện và triệu tối,
vẫn có thể sẻng ra các đợt năng cục bộ, có quan khi tựng cạnh báo khi tự năng nông sức hiện vừa hơn,
và gai gà thơi trụ bình dường năng, có thể làm giá tăng mùi cơ sốt nhật, được quyết i gió nhật,
cháy nổ tại khu vực dân cửa tiểu nước cục bộ. Nên được cao kéo dài, kết thật được ổng tấp cũng em hợp,
đăng tệ tệ sự khỏe vừa ra, chè nhỏ, cũng như vừa lâu đồng mấy chơi.